well as Jonah was saying the African
delegation is going to meet the Russian
president in the coming hours and
speaking at a forum in Saint Petersburg
on Friday Vladimir Putin warned of a
wider escalation
if Western supplies of F-16 fighter jets
are located at air bases outside Ukraine
and used in hostilities we will have to
look at how we can hit and where we can
hit those weapons that are used in
hostilities against us this is a serious
danger of NATO getting further drawn
into this armed conflict
in Moscow he's joining us live Ali as
Donna was explaining and not a lot of
enthusiasm or encouragement from
President Vladimir zielinski for the
African delegation any idea of what's
likely to happen when they meet
President Putin later on
relations between President Putin's
Russia and Africa has been on its best
in the past few years and this is of
course it's going to reflect on this
meeting that's also preceding an African
Russian Summit next month in Saint
Petersburg itself so the meeting is
going to be today maybe in the coming
hours and the African
delegation is going to present President
Putin with its Initiative for a solution
in Ukraine as Jonah said there are
several points in this initiative that
leads to a kind of de-escalation at the
beginning and later on talks and
negotiations to end this war however
this move by the African leaders also
emphasizes a new role for Africa in such
a global crisis whereas they are
presenting this initiative in order to
end this war that's kind of turning into
a very big and Global crisis that's
affecting almost all the continents so
President Putin will listen to whatever
the African leaders are to offer here in
in Saint Petersburg we are in Moscow but
the the meeting is going to be in Saint
Petersburg and it's expected that he is
going to react to this with just the
same uh speeches and the same rhetoric
that he's been repeating over the past
few months
there are kind of analysis that are kind
of reluctant to
put a lot of hopes on the African
initiatives
Ali we mentioned that Vladimir Putin had
been talking at this economic Forum now
obviously he was talking a great deal
about the Russian economy but he was
talking a little bit about the Ukraine
war as well what's he been saying
well mainly on the Ukraine war he
emphasized the position of his forces in
this special operation as he calls it uh
saying that the ukrainians are losing 10
soldiers for every uh one Russian
soldier and that Ukraine is depleting
its uh um domestic produced weapons for
the favor of a western produced weapons
and this is going to have a great impact
on Ukraine in the next uh phase of this
special operation as the Russians call
call it and also we highlighted the
issue of uh the new the use of nuclear
weapons and that the the more NATO is
involved in this war the more weapons
are being uh delivered and supplied to
the Ukrainian side the more there is a
possibility of that this special
operation could end up as a global war
or a World War as he said Ali thank you
very much indeed that's Ali Hashem
talking to us from muscle